le labo sensibiliser la population et
c'est de les inciter le maximum de 2 c
le plus possible à ne pas jeter leurs
piles à la poubelle c'est très mauvais
et encore moins par la fenêtre ou dont
la nation comment alors expliquer sur
les stones c'est ça ne peut être que
nocifs pour la nature et la santé
la contamination c'est un mètre carré
sur le sol deux mille mètres cubes d'eau
donc et de les jeter dans la poubelle
c'est pareil de toute manière ce qu'on
dit aux gens c'est qu'on peut refaire
des choses avec
alors s'ils peuvent acheter des piles
qui sont rechargeables tant mieux ça
évite de les jeter
mais par contre quand il les remercie il
les met dans les supermarchés etc
on peut refaire des cuillères des clés
des canettes et c'est tout ce qu'ils
utilisent chez de toute manière vous
sentez que ça marche accroche sur
intéressé alors cédé beewi sur les
premières étapes mais en fait une fois
que les gens ont répondu à des quizz ils
ont compris que le système fonctionnait
avec un quiz en répondre a dit qu est-ce
qu il y avait des cadeaux à gagner
ils étaient plus intéressés par les
cadeaux et finalement que par la
sensibilisation
c'est un peu dommage parce que comment
alors expliquer ces temps ci on a droit
aux sarcasmes peu partout ben ça peut
dépendre peut venir de ça aussi accéder
là on a essayé de concept exemple là
pour les sensibiliser au maximum mais
visiblement c'est plus l'occasion des 1
est ce que le comportement changera
selon vous après s'être passé chez vous
et pour la suite j'espère bien j'espère
il y en a qui sont motivés il y en a qui
veulent bien écouter qui effectivement
chez eux collecte les piles qui récupère
des mini partis box qu'on donne sur le
the stone qui récupère pour écouter les
piles chez eux mais on a d'autres comme
jeudi sont la police est pour les
tee-shirts
bon on espère qu'ils en feront bon usage
et qu'ils vont sensibiliser le voisinage
etc